AI is obviously All the Rage
um the entire menu was created by chat
GPT so those basically just typed in I
appreciate that I'm hosting a dinner for
a bunch of tech people X number of tech
people create a menu
um for an epic dinner party and it
created a full menu okay that's cool and
then it's like uh cool like uh generate
an image using dolly or whatever and
then basically created the whole menu
that way and the chef had to cook
whatever chat GPT had created which was
which is pretty clever
[Music]
what up uh before we go into this
episode I gotta say I'm doing a workshop
with our boy Nick Huber do you see this
uh just stay the w words for me
it's a workshop it's not a no say that
otherwise it's on the web
well it might be a webinar I might be
doing a website similar to a seminar on
the web
site
yeah I'm doing one of the lamest things
one man can do with another and that's a
webinar
all right well what's this webinar about
basically both of us are total um
I don't know nerds are just obsessed
with with hiring internationally like
for both of our companies I think we
both had a moment where like wait I'm
pretty sure I could find somebody for 10
times less you know it cost 10 times
less and the secret part that most
people don't realize everybody gets that
if you hire somebody overseas they're
they're cheaper
um what I found I don't know if you how
much you do this but they're way less
overseas mean like
um like across like the Mississippi
River in Missouri
[Laughter]
best deal uh like overseas like review
at the California you're gonna come into
uh you know like Hannibal Missouri no
basically I have let's see I got in one
of my in my e-commerce business I think
I have six or seven people in the
Philippines plus two in Latin America so
those are kind of the two hot spots
Latin America you get the same time zone
um and they're good for certain types of
roles like we have like data analytics
and stuff like that and then the
Philippines we have all of our customer
support plus like anything that's like
sales and Outreach so we'll just be like
hey we want to go get every influencer
on board I'm not even going to talk to
you just go go make that happen in every
morning report how many of how many
influencers are on board show me the
pipeline show me the hey we want this
many wholesalers to start selling our
stuff go make this happen and they're
just like an automated Sales Machine
which is pretty pretty amazing but
anyways we're doing this
webinar because uh yeah we just want to
give it away kind of like yeah you got
to call it a a web in our yeah yeah
we're gonna do it on the web
anyways we decided we'll do one we'll
teach anybody who uh it's like
delegation 101. uh but if you want to do
if you want to join or whatever it's on
the sixth I think a 6th of June well how
do people find it go to all right we're
gonna put on the screen a giant Link in
the description it'll be the top Link in
the podcast description and uh or the
YouTube notes but if you don't see any
of those places you can just go to my
website seanfree.com and it'll there'll
be a little Banner if you want to do it
because for doing this thing might as
well if we're doing it for free might as
well have as many people as we can set
up and if you sign up even though you
can't make it live you'll just get the
recording so if you ever want to then
hire internationally you'll have the
recording and all of our like kind of uh
our cheat codes of after doing this for
I don't know 10 years here's what works
here's what does it all right so we've
started on one end of the spectrum can
we please go to the other end of the
spectrum and tell me about a dinner you
had yeah I had this dinner I thought I
already talked about it but I don't
think billionaire dinner is a great way
to go when we started with the weapon
yeah exactly see what happens is you
hire people for low cost then you go to
this billionaire that's basically what I
did so I went to a dinner at a
Billionaire's place and I can't say
exactly who
but I want to share three takeaways from
this thing
are they a billionaire from being early
at a tech company or for starting
something amazing starting their own
tech companies so do they sell it or is
it still yeah at this dinner there was
somebody who sold their business for I
think I could say some of the people who
were there so uh let me let me try to do
that there was uh the guy who created
figma was there so sold his company
recently for 20 billion so he was there
uh there was people that were like
really internet ogs like they were like
their first internet company was in 98
or something like that and so I well
that's the part I actually loved I was
talking to them so that's the story I
want to show those people are the best
they're the best because I was like what
was it like back in the early days and
I'm gonna tell you one thing that he
told me but before I do that a couple of
interesting things now I've done a
couple of these didn't run yeah how did
you get invited to this
I know one of the people there so they
they what they do is they host these
regularly
um with the same crew but then whoever
is the host for that month gets to
invite guests so they were they get to
invite three or four guests that are not
in the main group to kind of spice up
the dinner but then the main group is
like been going for 10 years plus so
it's kind of aspirational I was like oh
I'm gonna start one of these too it's a
a once a month dinner with a red with a
core crew and then whoever's the host
for that month gets to pick the food
um and I think you do like a special
gift like um Reid Hoffman who's the
creator of LinkedIn was in the group or
whatever and when when it was his turn
to host I remember that uh he created
like his own board game of uh like an
anti like is it Cards Against Trump like
his own version of Cards Against
Humanity but it was just Trump jokes and
he gave one to every guest right so just
like baller like that
um
so anyways I'm at this dinner and I
would say three observations I've been
to a couple of these dinners somehow
every dinner I go to in San Francisco is
like at least 30 to 50 percent people
talking about psychedelics
and yeah
your boy's never done psychedelics sober
is a cat not once no no not once way too
scared to do it uh have you ever done
psychedelics I don't even really
honestly know what would count a second
I think it's like LSD I think it's like
MDMA I think it's DMT these are all the
letters but I I don't I don't partake in
any acronyms like this and one time I
met this girl uh and we went out on like
a first or maybe it was the second date
and this is when I was still drinking so
we were a little drunk and then we also
took shrooms and a little bit of a
ecstasy or Molly or MDMA or I don't even
know any of them so I felt I definitely
felt a little bit of all of them but I
was also like pretty intoxicated too so
I like it was you know a little bit you
know maybe 50 of the potency but that
was the only time I've ever done it and
that was uh you know 15 years ago the
only acronym I have done is dare and
that kept me off all this so but but I
gotta say so I've done three of these
dinners now in San Francisco with like
entrepreneurial type successful silicon
types and
it's crazy how much people talk about uh
psychedelics like half the table
is our regular users of psychedelics or
like you know regular meaning it wasn't
a like your story of like I did it once
and you know it was it was cool but not
not for me or whatever
um dude I wasn't trying to like find
myself I was just trying to like you
know have a freaky night find her yeah
yeah we're trying to find something but
it wasn't myself I was sort of by myself
like you know like with each other later
that evening but that's about it and so
in these conversations to me there's
what what's coming up is not like
it's not bro I got so drunk it's not a
brag like that it's
I the the conversation is like this
weird intellectual thing where it's like
one-third talking about how psychedelics
or else he's cool one-third talking
about public policy like I can't believe
these are outlawed it's crazy this is
there's and then one third is science
it's like there's dude I don't give a
about any of those topics there is
so much research about how this can like
cure PTSD and like blah blah
and it just keeps happening every dinner
I've gone to in San Francisco three in a
row now half the conversation is talking
about this which tells me one of two
things it's a potpourri in the middle of
the table like fart flavored is that
like is that what this place is like
I'll tell you about that in a second
they um the the thing with with these is
is I've had this experience once before
or twice before where
a lot of people in Silicon Valley are
talking about something that I'm like ah
this seems weird and then like five
years later it's the norm or seven years
later it's the total Norm so there is
this thing that's like
um Paul Graham says if you want to
invent the future you first just live in
it and and I think that's one of the
things that silica Valley is pretty good
at is people here will do things like
whether it's like like what you're doing
biohacking where you're wearing
continuous glucose monitors like Tim
Ferriss was wearing a continuous glucose
monitor back in like
2008 or something like that and then a
decade later now it's like a thing that
a lot of Fitness people are doing this
whole startups that are built around uh
letting you do this like nutrisense or
levels whatever and uh but it was very
strange at the time but there were this
like small community of people doing it
same thing with crypto back in 2012
there was people going to these meetups
that were like all about Bitcoin and
then they seem like you know the biggest
kind of freaks at the time uh 2011 2012
and then a decade later it's on CNBC
every day so like I've seen this a few
times in Silicon Valley where they're
somewhat ahead of the curve but of
course
it's like anything uh that's at like you
know a little bit contrarian it's not
always just because it's weird doesn't
mean it's always going to be a thing
but the Psychedelic conversation that
was cool 10 years ago now it's it's I
mean you can go to I mean I see everyone
on Facebook saying I just got back from
some country where we did an Ayahuasca
Retreat I mean like I don't think that's
normal for most people I think that's
like your circle uh and our my circle a
little bit more than it is the average
person all right so that was one one
piece of it second
AI is obviously All the Rage
um the entire menu was created by
chatgpt so it was basically just typed
in I appreciate that I'm hosting a
dinner for a bunch of tech people X
number of tech people create a menu
um for an epic dinner party and it
created a full menu okay that's cool uh
write the whole thing like a
Shakespearean uh Shakespearean play and
I said I just translated the menu into
like this like very flowery poem
basically and then it's like uh cool
like uh generate an image using Dolly
whatever and then basically created the
whole menu that way and the chef had to
cook whatever Chad CPT had created which
was which was pretty clever uh including
like the drinks and whatever
um so I thought that was that was fun
and then the last thing I want to say is
I was talking to one guy
and I didn't ask him if I could say this
so I don't want to uh say his name
necessarily uh but he's one of those
internet ogs and I was like
I was like so what's your story and he's
like well I started a business back in
he says the name of this company that
like I've heard of from the.com boom and
then like you know disappeared after
that and I was like oh wow like um
that's interesting and I was like so
what was it like back then you know
doing a startup here he's like he's like
it was crazy he said I knew every single
person doing a startup he's like he's
like we used to have like uh like in San
Francisco here we used to have these
meetups he's like we would meet up once
a month
and
he's like it started out with just me
and this one guy he named the guy who I
think I can name this guy who's the guy
who started next door
um this guy nirav tolia and he's like me
and nerve were like hey let's get
together a bunch of anybody else who you
know that's like interested in this Tech
like internet thing like our fellow
nerds yeah like if they if you know
anybody doing internet stuff let's
invite him to this thing and then they
created this group and he's like dude
the group was insane he's like it was
the guy who went to go you know like the
guy who created
um Zynga then the guy who created
LinkedIn the guy who created YouTube the
guy who created PayPal like all of them
he's like we would just hang out like it
was just like like you know we used to
those Mastermind dinners in San
Francisco he's like it was like that
he's like at that time you didn't know
who any of these people were you didn't
know who's special who wasn't you just
knew we're all super interested in the
internet to add three zeros to like our
success and that was it was basically
the same thing exactly and so he's like
um
he's like we would get together and it
was just like debates about like what's
going on with the internet and like what
cool stuff you're seeing
and he's like we would just shoot the
late until the night he's like and
then afterwards uh it started growing
he's like so I started growing then we
had like too many people for one table
so we made two tables I was the host of
one and the other guy was the host of
the other table let's lead that
discussion then afterwards we would
compare notes and be like who should we
invite back he's like the key was the
internet started growing in popularity
like crazy like a lot of people wanted
to do internet companies the way that we
made the community work was we started
pruning hardcore so he's like we were
like the bigger the overall Community
gets the more high level this one needs
to get so let's let's only invite Pac
people that we think are like the most
dynamic the people who are going to do
the most interesting things he's like so
dude he's like this would have been the
best Venture portfolio of all time like
it was like every internet company
that's big now they were there and then
even the people who were like you'll
have like a Jack Dorsey or something
like that it's like they hadn't even
done their big thing yet and they're
kind of the junior guy at this thing
hanging out right that's I don't know if
he specifically was doing it but he gave
me some some names of some examples of
people that were there because I was
like like who could you tell
at that time was gonna do something like
who did he say he's like I felt like
half the group he's like basically we as
he's like what we did was
when somebody's like stood out of
somebody that that really kind of knew
where the puck was going we made them a
table host so they would host their own
table by the end we had like eight nine
tables going and did he say
of anyone the question I would have
asked was the opposite is who's a mega
success who you thought oh that doofus I
can't believe he he turned into
something yeah and I he did tell me a
couple of stories but on both directions
people he thought was just this person's
an animal they're gonna do great things
and somebody who's a little overrated I
don't want to say because you know if
they figured out that I don't want them
to be upset or whatever but I would say
like one of the things he told me was
it wasn't
it wasn't the people who were working on
ideas that sounded big so all the people
that ended up with a big thing
the things they were working on weren't
the things that sounded like important
businesses from day one
and they became important they became
eventually iterated too no no like it
was a bigger space than we all realized
um it was like it was basically the
person that was like kind of like doing
the thing that was most interesting to
them and not necessarily they're like
okay internet's gonna be a big deal so
therefore I'm gonna create
this important sounding real world
business on the internet it wasn't that
it was like
okay yeah this is cool that people are
doing this like like social networking
at the time was not seen as
a space that was going to yield 100
billion dollar companies right like it
wasn't that wasn't a thing that was uh
that sounded like the frivolous fun
thing it's like oh cool you like
you can like create a profile like take
a quiz yeah you can like write something
silly on their wall or whatever like
that didn't seem like the big ideas and
like all the Big Ideas seem like you
know even like things like
um so it was like breaking the three
categories like things that you didn't
think were gonna happen on the internet
selling cars booking travel like you
know it wasn't like it's like are people
gonna do that or maybe like home home
buying it's like I don't know maybe that
seems like something you really want to
do in the real world it's like those
seemed like kind of Fringe because I
don't know if people will do it it was
social networking that seemed Fringe and
small and that's fun but not not that
interesting because we don't it's free
how are we gonna make a big business out
of this
um you know what are you gonna do with
all these free users that are just going
on there and goofing off and then then
there was like you know the things that
were actually like important sounding
businesses so I thought that was kind of
interesting too and it reminds me of
have you seen this uh clip this is my
last thing on this look up nfx on Tick
Tock so nfx is a uh is an investment
fund an NSX inside insights that's
exactly right yeah okay I'm on their
page watch that first video we'll put
this in the YouTube video but uh watch
this first video real quick of James
Courier standing there all right it says
everyone in that stuff is all in on
generative AI so there's an underground
scene of startups this kind of
Revolution happens every 14 years and
Builders are here to change the world
and it's James carrier who's on a stage
or like a he's on a chair in a room full
of like 20 guys
chair your exceed performance indicators
with each other and he's saying to
people share your ideas the speed of
which you move is what gives you and
this town
and this community it's Advantage and
it's uh 65 of all money invested in AI
it's being invested in San Francisco
right now so he's given this pump up
speech where he's trying to say like
you know years ago there was like the
Facebooks
but just let you know this is happening
right now with AI and he's in a room
with people like giving this cool speech
and everyone's like staring up at him
they seem like they're super into it
it's it's so cool so he's literally like
you could see a staircase coming down so
he's somewhere downstairs in like a
basement he's standing on a chair and
he's in a room full of people and he's
like basically gives them a rally speech
of like
look this is where the magic happens
he's like you're in this town you're in
this room you're with a bunch of
Builders and what he says is every 14
years or so
one of these waves happen and they last
somewhere between 24 to 36 months and
he's talking about AI he's like um he's
like we've seen this before with mobile
so mobile comes out and there's this
three-year window between kind of like
2009 to 2012. it happened with the
internet and I was like you know kind of
like 99 2000 to kind of 2000 and
3 2004. and he's like you get 36 to
maybe 48 months Max to
um to take advantage of this moment and
you're in this room you're with other
people there's some like basically like
there's somebody in this room right now
who's building the next big thing I you
know I hope it's you but you want to
trade ideas trade strategies trade what
you're like doing find interesting
people work on projects with them invest
in each other like this is your time to
focus these windows only open up for a
small period of time move as fast as you
can and I thought it was pretty I
thought it was pretty dope uh to see
this kind of like
I don't know this
this like I don't know rally cry and it
really does seem like that's what's
happening with with artificial
intelligence right now like there's a
window the big shit's gonna get built
right now the the next kind of Facebooks
of the world are are being built right
now and um it's just kind of
re-highlights the intensity of the
moment if you're an entrepreneur have
you heard that parable about like
there's this guy who uh he's uh there's
a big flood and he's on this roof and a
guy with a boat comes by and goes hey uh
come on get in my boat I need to save
you and the guy on the roof goes no no
I'm praying to God and I'm a religious
guy he got to save me and he goes all
right another guy comes on the boats
it's the same thing and he goes no no
I'm not gonna get in that boat I'm gonna
wait for the uh a guy to come and save
me the habits two or three times the guy
eventually drowned and dies he goes to
heaven he goes god what the hell why
didn't you come and save me and guy goes
dude I had four boats come and get you
like what did you what did you just hop
in that was me this video the reason
it's similar to that is there's this
like James carrier who he's wearing like
pretty much an ugly shirt that's like a
he's wearing like a he's wearing like a
tucked in t T-shirt into blue jeans kind
of dad Gene I mean he looks like a dad
he's probably he's a dad yeah he's a
deep five so he looks like he should and
he's wearing like kind of an ugly shirt
and he's like just a normal looking guy
I guess is what I mean and he's giving
this really nice speech but in a
basement and it's that same thing where
like everyone's looking for some big
opportunity and from like Grand like
Epiphany moment it's like no it's just
some guy who dress like dresses like
this he's in a basement yeah he's
telling you like the message is here the
message is here and the message is clear
he's trying to shake you by the he's
trying to grab you by the collar and
Shake you and be like hey
this like play time is over the window
is open go and uh
I love it I think that's I think it's
100 true and I I want to leave with two
controversial opinions
it's a video with 6 000 views this is
this is the man in the boat trying to
save you from drowning yeah but by the
way the best stuff like the best content
I consume the most insightful meaningful
content I consume is all like this it's
got like 1200 views on YouTube it's got
you know 6 000 views on Tick Tock the
best stuff is not the most popular stuff
when it comes to like business stuff you
used to host hustlecon and people had to
fly out to San Francisco pay a couple
hundred bucks for their ticket spend all
day do that not everybody could do that
nobody could afford to flight the hotel
the ticket take a day off work blah blah
you put all the talks up on YouTube
every single one of them was on YouTube
it's in fact it's on our Channel on
YouTube Just scroll back all the way to
the oldest videos all the talks are
there
and all the talks have like 400 views
it's crazy it's like oh you want to be
successful oh really the same thing like
Harvard's whole curriculum is like
online you can go take any Harvard class
you want online and people will cry
about not like not having the the
opportunities that the rich Harvard kids
have what are you talking about all the
classes are online you can take off
YouTube right now yeah have the same
education that Gates had that Zuckerberg
had access to you got access to all of
it
and they'll have like 900 views and it
just shows you that like the the the
real ones are gonna go do the thing the
those 900 views are like the valuable
people like I want to go meet all 900
people that are that are watching those
videos because those are the people that
are actually finding so that's take away
one
that's Oh no you're two my two two
controversial things
San Francisco is back baby and the
second thing is this whole like idea of
moving away to lower your taxes and
moving away to be remote
the best teams are going to be working
together they're going to be in the room
with each other especially pre-product
Market fit but I will take any team
that's co-located over a remote team any
day just head to head if it was a
competition I would take the the team
that's going to be in there every day
having a bunch of serendipitous
conversations whiteboarding ideas
getting to know each other better
because they're just spending a like
absurd obscene amount of time together I
would rather have those people that are
willing to commit and go all in like
that over a distributed remote team
where you're spending half your day
actually you know walking your dog and
taking care of your kids and doing all
this stuff I think they're just gonna
outperform and I think that San
Francisco is going to outperform I think
that
going to the the dense city as I the
people who care about the extra 10 in
taxes or the people who are like oh I
don't want to live here because
um you know I don't like the DA's policy
on crime
you know I I just think that that's I
think it's insane that people in a in a
game where the upside is like thousand X
returns that people optimize for a 10
break in state income tax it's crazy to
me yeah but bro you don't even live in
San Francisco
stone's throw away as they say
I'm across the bridge
one person can throw a rack that bar I
don't
know catapult for them
I'm one easy pass away
[Laughter]
I agree with everything you're saying
and find this client info have you heard
of HubSpot
application every team can stay aligned
no out of sync spreadsheets or dueling
databases HubSpot grow better
all right this next statement we're
gonna call it three killer Asians and
it's about three people uh one of those
two of those people is a couple that
you're gonna talk about but I'll go
first
and the reason I'm breaking this up so
this week so let me preface by saying I
don't know anything about like public
markets I I I'm a I'm a index investor I
don't do anything like crazy and so I
don't know much but
this week I paid attention to my
portfolio did you pay attention to yours
there was a nice little bump I have not
checked what's going on
so
stocks are doing well the tech sector is
doing well and I emailed my banker I
texted him I go Griffin what's going on
man why uh why why do I have so much
more money than I did the day before and
he said
Nvidia just crushed their earnings and
like a lot of people out there I know
the name Nvidia I know that Nvidia is a
company but I don't really know what
they do do you know what Nvidia does
they make chips they make the chips that
go into your uh like you buy a gaming PC
the graphics the GPU in there is going
to be made by Nvidia it's like Intel
bikes chips and Nvidia makes chips and
AMD makes chips there's like three
companies that make chips okay so do me
a favor do you have Google up Google
Gary Oldman so the word Dairy and then
almond o l
e-m-a-n you know you see who that is
old man like old man
you see it uh it's pulling up it's an
actor very old yeah you see it you see
it yeah you see you see Gary all right
you recognize Gary yeah see this guy
around
yeah okay type in another guy named Gary
Cole you see Gary Cole
yeah another actor okay and and what's
your reaction when you see him
um I have no reaction to this guy what
am I supposed to be reacting to you just
like seeing them around right oh yeah
sure it looks like he looks like a guy
Nvidia is like the Gary's uh the tech
world has no idea where you're going
with that
so Gary Allman for those of you who
watch the computer Gary Oldman was the
chief on Dark Knight like the like the
top or in the Dark Knight the guy who
puts up the bat signal yeah yeah he was
also uh Whitson Churchill and like that
The Darkest Hour movie He plays all
these roles for like you see him and
you're like oh that guy's great he's
awesome he's always there he always has
a good performance and everything he's
in it's probably pretty good but like
he's never like the guy and he's never
like I can't tell you who he is I don't
have to look it up same with like you
know there's a bunch of these actors who
are like that that's what Nvidia is of
the tech world so basically
and this isn't going to sound like
obvious to anyone who's like is in deep
Tech but for someone like me who's not I
had to like figure out what Nvidia is so
basically the story is is that they
create GPU as a GPU chips or the GPU
they invented it so prior to Nvidia
there was like these other chip
companies and uh they like intel was one
of them just like the big dogs who you
have heard about the 70s and 80s and
they just make chips that ran your
computer whatever but then as computers
got a little bit better uh Jensen hung
the founder he was like look we need to
have a 3D chip for 3D or a chip or 3D
video and graphic process so basically
like we can like our screens will be
more interactive and all that and so he
invents this chip and he runs the
company now for 30 years so he's been
CEO for of this company longer than any
other like newish tech company and he
made this bet and it wasn't that big of
a bet so when he launched in 1993 he
raised a two million dollar round of
funding at a six million dollar
valuation so this wasn't like some like
you're gonna crush this like it was just
a normal startup at the time but he
makes this bet that he thinks that um
that uh ctus which is what people used
to use that that's going to be like a
little bit less popular and gpus which
is for graphics and like more General
use that's going to be like the thing
and so the first people who start using
it are Gamers so in like different
gaming PCs people start using it and
then Apple Microsoft whatever they're
like oh man we actually also want some
of these chips so we're going to use
that but now it's expanded Way Beyond
that so like Tesla uses their chips so
like when you want to like do
self-driving they've got an Nvidia chip
that helps them figure out like where
people are uh
um you know the camera will will use the
GPU chip and then it will put like you
know when you're on a Tesla you can see
people walking across the street uh and
then now they're even using for
artificial intelligence so anyone who's
using like open AI Amazon web services
things like that they're also using GPU
and so this company
it's one of those companies that you
don't really think about because it's a
B2B company but at this point and this
is what shocked me Nvidia is now either
the 7th or eighth largest company in the
world is that insane well and so like
this company because their stock did
well the whole NASDAQ which is like a
tax uh a tech based
um index the market cap there's almost
one trillion it's 963 billion right now
it's insane right so because Nvidia
popped the whole NASDAQ the whole NASDAQ
which is a a tech-based uh a tech
forward like Stock Exchange that's what
I meant not indexes they're killing it
because of that and so I have no idea I
like heard that name and me I'm like
what is this little like gaming company
how is this like moving the stock market
and that's what it is and this guy uh
the founder the um the acquired guys
have a really good episode on him his
name's Jensen he's like really
interesting so he was a Taiwanese
immigrant and he his parents didn't have
any money so they sent him to like a
boarding school which is like a reform
school for kids who had issues and like
his roommate was this guy who had just
got out of prison at the age of like 16
or 17 and he had been stabbed like 50
times and so the guy was like Hey keep
me out of your work computers and I'll
show you how to lift weights and so if
you look at this guy now Jensen he's
like a pretty buff guy and he also has
like the word Nvidia the Nvidia logo
tattooed on him and he like says I'll be
like really wild things like he'll say
by Will to survive is greater than
almost anyone's will to kill me and like
yeah all these phrases where he just
says like I'm all in baby and so he's a
really interesting entrepreneur but he's
like the Gary Oldman of the world where
we don't actually like he's not up there
like we're not watching videos of him
like Mark Zuckerberg doing Jiu Jitsu
because he's not like a mainstream
facing guy but now I think it's gonna
change because they are absolutely
crushing it and I'm one the many people
who probably had no idea what they do
yeah when the acquired guys came on our
pod I think you asked them you're like
hey you studied all these companies you
studied all these these epic Titans of
business
um
and I think you said like who would you
not want to compete with or who would
you want to compete with the least
and uh they said this guy Jensen Wong
they were like Jensen the guy from
Nvidia the leather jacket wearing CEOs
got the Nvidia tattoo on his shoulder
who has just been like you know a
monster for like you know 20 years with
this company and that was not the answer
like I wouldn't have guessed that that's
who they would have said
um and it was it it was an unfulfilling
answer because I was like well I don't
know anything about this guy and I bet
most of our listeners were like Oh I
thought you would have said Mark
Zuckerberg or someone famous and this
guy's just quietly kind of behind the
scenes although he is like a loud
personality he's not he doesn't seem
obnoxious but he wears like a cool
leather jacket and he looks like very
confident but he's just been quietly
behind the scenes kind of killing it I
don't know what his net worth is now but
I bet you he's one of like the top 30 or
50 richest people in America or uh in
the world at the moment and he just gave
a talk at like
Taiwanese like National University or
something like that and he I haven't
seen it yet as I guess commencement
speech
um and like you remember this the Steve
Jobs like the great one like the the one
he did at Stanford that was like just
like incredible
um
he that he gave a talk I haven't seen
the whole thing but there's a couple of
lessons some people have tweeted out I
want to share a couple with you so he's
like uh he goes lesson number one
humility he goes
confront failure head-on and ask for
help so he says back in the day or the
uh one year in the early days of Nvidia
they got their first big chip contract
and it was with Sega the video game
console and he goes after a year of
development they realized that they had
picked the wrong technical strategy to
make the chip that was going to do the
things the Sega needed to fulfill the
contract and he's like we realize our
architecture was the wrong strategy he's
like uh you know we didn't know what to
do should we scramble try to make it
work should we just deliver something
that's not great like what should we do
should we start over we don't have time
he's like so I just called the CEO Sega
and I was like hey I think you have to
find another partner
um but I also need you to keep paying us
on the contract these are
these things like I hate to even ask
this I'm embarrassed if you like if we
don't have this money we're gonna go out
of business
um like if you just please pay out the
rest of this contract like I'm
embarrassed to even ask you this but
um we need these six months to survive
and uh We've we screwed up uh you know
I'll do everything in my power to help
you do this and I'll try to make it
right after this but like if we don't
have this if we don't pay this contract
it's over the show's over for us and the
CFC uh Sega agreed he actually paid it
out they gave him six months to survive
he's like you got to confront your
mistakes head on with humility and ask
for help that saved it video
um he's like this is the hardest thing
to learn for somebody who's the the
smart and successful type they try to uh
you know avoid failure or be a denial or
uh or hide from it what else did it say
he goes second is uh lesson number two
you have to endure the pain and
suffering to realize your dream so he
goes uh in 2007 we announced uh Cuda
this like new way to like kind of like
program your gpus I think that's the
real key for NVIDIA they don't just make
the chips they make the pro they make
the this Cuda thing is important so
especially the way that people
developers can use gpus and like uh
control the GPU to do what they want so
by the way they don't even make the
chips they like design them and they
have a partnership at this other time
which is why like sometimes they'll say
like you'll hear things like well Taiwan
gets invaded by China we're at risk the
eighth largest company in the world is
going to be kind of screwed which means
XYZ for the rest yeah especially all the
companies that need chips uh like oh all
of our cars need chips all of our
computers need chips all of our phones
that need chips if we lose control of
the chips it's like losing the nukes or
it's like losing access to oil it's like
a big deal so anyways um so he goes he
goes you know we basically we tried to
create this thing back in 2007 uh it was
super hard super expensive our profits
took a huge hit and we had many years of
poor performance and our shareholders
were skeptical like dude why are you
spending all this money on this stupid
like gpus Cuda thing like you need to
improve profitability blah blah he's
like but we just said no we're gonna
keep doing this and basically it took
like 3 four years before there was even
a market for this but by the time there
was a market for this they were so far
ahead he's like so then the phone comes
out the phone phones become a huge
success now phones need gpus and by 2010
they had the lead in the mobile chip
market so uh chips for phones and he's
like that was huge and um oh no sorry
the uh I screwed up the story The gpus
Thing becomes a big deal as gaming
continues to go that direction and like
all the AI machine learning stuff but
like that was it took like you know
almost 10 years for that to come through
but they like stuck to their guns and
stuck with it even though the
shareholders and the the public markets
were punishing them for it and then last
one he's like you know we were in the
mobile chip Market we were the leader
and he's like um but it just became so
competitive it was so many people
fighting for the same pie they basically
decided to like sacrifice
um sacrifice the mobile market and leave
that in order to do to uh to go for like
you know a different Market this kind of
AI machine learning market and again it
seemed like a terrible strategic bet
it's like you're leaving the biggest
Market cell phones in order to go for
this like unknown like you know risky
thing and that strategic bet paid off
because they became you know the by far
the leader in this field and uh and now
that became like you know the biggest
Market the market everybody's bullish
about and the reason their stock is up
so much is because
they like gave guidance like they had
like a revenue Target or forecast or
whatever there was a revenue forecast
and they like just came out like uh
actually we think we're gonna Crush that
by like 30 and they're like wait 30 on a
number that's already in the
multi-billions and they're like yes and
so the stock took off after that
dude it's awesome so I'm a big fan I'm a
big fan of the sky soaps is it huh or or
I don't know the The Silent Age there
are always a challenge for me but Mr
Jensen I've been in media you are
today's killer Asian number one shot
tell me who are killer agent number two
and three all right we're going from
a guy who makes gpus and and AI
artificial intelligence
to orange chicken
I butchered the joke it was too good
excuse me you heard to MSC so I met
somebody who was like a real estate
person and they were like uh
I was like yeah you know how's the real
estate thing going they're like oh dude
it's going great we're growing growing
growing
I was like so you're still just doing
this all with your own money and he's
like yeah although there's one person
who wants to put money in that I'll take
and I was like but you've always said no
to anybody's money like why who's this
one person and why why are you
interested you guys
it's the guy who started Panda Express
this guy's a billion like
multi-billionaire
and he's got so much money
he's got an unbelievable amount of money
that he doesn't know what to do with it
I was like you know he's like he needs a
place to invest this money and I was
like Panda Express like how much money
are they making and I kind of looked
into it so this is this segment is Panda
Express the 10 billion dollar Mom and
Pop
so I don't know how much you know about
Panda Express but a bit it does uh I
know you've uh you've tested the the
goods so
so basically it's a privately owned
company so it's just owned by this
husband and wife
it does about 5 billion a year in sales
5.3 billion last year there are no
franchises like of this thing so they
kind of independently own I think almost
all there might be like a hundred that
are like in international territories
that they don't control but for the most
part they've grown this thing to a huge
International chain it's I think the
third biggest fast food chain or
something like that it's like you know
just behind uh you know sort of like the
the the huge ones the McDonald's and
Chick-fil-A's of the world and um
they're on track to become a 10 billion
dollar
mom and pop company which is just kind
of insane and my friend who I uh who who
was telling me what other names what's
that uh Andrew like churn I don't know
how you say it exactly it's like a churn
it's c-h-e-r-n-g or something like that
uh it's him and his wife and they they
vote this thing they've earned this
thing so he started the first one it was
like called the the Panda Inn back in
the day it was like a normal restaurant
I think he was not I think he started it
yeah I think his dad had one his dad was
like so so his dad was a was a chef and
he he opened up panda in and his dad was
the chef of that restaurant and then he
then fast food started taking off and
Andrew got pretty fascinated with this
idea of fast food and was like
okay what if we did Chinese fast food
and so they the second or third location
they did was this like Express this like
fast and it was in California right yeah
but there was more agents and they
um and they start doing a bunch of
things that are smart so some of the
Strategic smart things that they did was
uh
um they opened up a bunch of locations
as they grew in airports and military
bases which a lot of people weren't
doing at the time but they were like oh
this is a great way to build awareness
like these are like huge hubs that a lot
of people come through if we're here we
will become like known and normal as
like uh as like a Cuisine basically and
so they did those even though those
aren't the most profitable locations
they did it kind of like for the brand
the second thing they
um the uh his wife was like a food
engineer or something like that and so
she was one of the first people in
Chinese restaurants to use a whole bunch
of tech so Tech to monitor inventory or
measure speed for for operations and
that's why they became so efficient and
they called themselves McDonald's of the
East because they're as efficient as a
McDonald's even though almost every
other kind of like
Chinese restaurant was it was a
traditional mom and pop they didn't you
know they write down the orders by hand
they you know they track inventory by
going to open up the fridge and eyeball
and everything and being like I think we
need to order more eggs
um whereas they turned this into kind of
like a machine and they would find
things that were working in one store so
like this guy in Hawaii who owned one of
the who's running one of the stores the
chef there he created orange chicken and
he's like oh I think I could take you
know that one beef dish that's an
appetizer that uses the orange peels I
think I could use that orange thing on
the general Style's chicken and like
combine the two have this fried chicken
that's got the orange flavor so Panda
Express invented orange chicken that's
what it sounded like for my my reading
now I don't know if there's others that
are debating that but that's that's how
they frame it at least and they sell 100
million pounds of orange chicken a year
it's like the same crazy number and so
uh yeah just the same thing so I think
they do almost like like 800 million
dollars of ebitda
incredible amount of money
I know someone who knows him and he told
me the same number yeah he told me he
goes he goes knocking on the door he
goes they're knocking on the door of a
billion in ebitda exactly what do you do
with all this money and people have
asked him like are you going to take it
public and the cfo's like never this is
going to be a family business they'll
pass it down from generation to
generation our job is to make this a
multi-generational family-owned business
and uh I think that's really cool like
there's so few of those that like refuse
to go public and why do they need to
they're rolling in profits right like
they don't they don't need the liquidity
of the markets they don't have investors
that they need to pull off I couldn't
find if there was like some Angel
Investors early on that there probably
was something I don't know if they own
literally 100 but it is uh it seems like
it's either 100 or close to it in terms
of their ownership which I think is is
kind of insane
he also does a few other things so
um if I remember correctly I might get
some of the details wrong but I think
that piece the day you start working
there I believe he like even like at the
I think this is like as a cashier not
just like H2 but as like a a retail
worker I'd say he buys you the book
um How to Win Friends and Influence
People by Dale Carnegie because he said
that when he I don't know if he is I
think he might be an immigrant but his
parents were for sure immigrants and he
was like trying to figure out how to
like assimilate and how to like be more
likable and charismatic so he could like
uh get along with uh Americans and he
read How to Win Friends and Influence
People and it like changed his life uh I
also think he read like they can grow
rich and so he like gives people these
books and he also sponsors tons of his
employees to go to Tony Robbins stuff so
he's like all about this like self-help
stuff which is cool we got a bunch in
common we have a bunch of comment and he
likes that for his employees and so I
think if I if I had to guess when you
get to be the size of uh a hundred
million pounds of orange chicken
you're no longer like a product company
or just like a restaurant company you're
a collecting people and making sure that
they all behave in a very particular
type of way as well as like a logistics
company and so in terms of like you know
like there's a reason why McDonald
whenever they know something it's like
oh that's this huge announcement just
because you have to make ribs like dude
because they have to go and like get
like a you know 500 pounds of pork in
order to like make this it's like a huge
ordealous but in terms of treating his
people well and like collecting people
and he like invests I heard uh into them
a whole lot so he's kind of like a
really interesting guide I don't know if
this is like PR spun stuff where all uh
you know he looks great all the time uh
just from the outside but he seems like
he does a lot of really good good stuff
there's a I I just asked uh Chaturbate
for some fun facts I said give me some
some fun anecdotes about them and they
said the thing about the the books said
he buys uh thousands of copies of uh of
his favorite books one is like Awakening
the Buddha within and gives it to his
employees another thing that it says is
according to Forbes article
um staff members often start the day
with affirmations like people are
depending on me to be at my best I
believe in myself and my abilities
opportunities are everywhere and I don't
know if that's that's truly how they
start their day but it's a hell of a lot
better than just saying the Pledge of
Allegiance I think we should put this in
schools
um yeah it's crazy I mean 2 000 Plus
stores as a kind of family owned
and non-franchised out business is
mind-boggling level of scale to reach
um he also understand his wife Peggy
that just like still kind of like owned
the thing
and he does the total opposite of what
you just said before he moved to Nevada
um he now looks at the best friend
because he's making so much income but
yeah I know that he I think Nevada's now
it was like a big deal when he left
California and to Nevada that's his
physical state I think it's about tech
entrepreneurs if you were if you are
gonna build a uh silica Valley style
Venture startup this this is the place
to be for that I'm not saying everybody
in the world should live in California
if you're if you're uh if you're if
you're slinging 100 million pounds of
orange chicken you live wherever the
hell you want that's that's rule number
three
I want you to tell me we're gonna move
into the last section here I want you to
tell me you got a little ambitious here
you titled the section famous people who
are back with new companies I don't want
to call them famous maybe noticeable
somewhat popular notable notable notable
is a better one let's do notable tell me
what you got
I don't know if you've seen this but
there's a few people who are well known
in our industry for for a bunch of
reasons that are doing interesting
things I want to get your quick reaction
to each of them so I don't know if
you've seen all these but uh but we'll
start with uh Naval so Naval is uh kind
of like the I know one of the Godfathers
of uh Southern Valley's been here again
since that kind of like
pre.com boom days he did a startup that
went public and then he uh you know
famously got a big dispute with a bunch
of people about it he created a a Blog
that was called Venture hacks and then
him and his partner nivi and they that
became that eventually sort of led to
angelist which is a multi-billion dollar
startup that's like LinkedIn for the
tech industry and he's known he's got
like a million plus followers on Twitter
because very insightful guy so Naval is
awesome
he's like a self-appointed guru which is
brilliant but he's actually I think he's
a non-self-appointed guru I think other
people appoint him a guru and he's like
that makes me a little uncomfortable but
I kind of like it
he lead he leaned into it but I've as
somebody who's consumed I think every
word that Duvall has said somehow like
I've watched all his live streams his
podcast all that stuff right love his
stuff he um many times we'll be like
people you know people be like why don't
you do more or have your own things and
he's like I don't want I don't
I don't like
this playing this role of this Guru
thing I don't like how much I like it
and I have to be very careful that I
don't fall into that
um I don't want that to be my life and
my identity and get excited about oh I'm
gonna I'm just excited about learning
this thing because I'm gonna go tell
everybody about it and then everybody's
gonna think I'm so smart he's like no I
don't want that I want to learn the
thing because I like to learn it and
that's it
um and he's like you know he's like I
you know like it's like junk food when
he's like I get on here and I give
random advice to people it's my junk
food it's not what I want to be eating
and people base their lives on it
but it is far yeah Justin's got the
Nvidia tattoo I got the naval tattoo on
my arm okay so what's air Chat thing
have you seen it have you played with it
okay yeah isn't it just like
a little bit but is it it almost felt
like an AI friend is that what it is no
not at all so it's a app it's kind of
like a social media app so you open it
up and there's these like rooms so you
can go into a room that's like it might
be people talk about Ai and it's sort of
like uh it's audio but it's recorded so
I could go on there and I could be like
you know I was playing with this chat
thing one of the cool things that I've
been doing is this has anybody tried
anything that's uh blown their mind that
blew my mind and then another person who
follows me can just reply be like uh
dudes are totally right here's what I
did and you're hearing their voice it's
like voice plus the transcription of it
so it's kind of like a a way to have
almost like a podcasty style thing where
you're having a conversation but it's
it's open like anybody can kind of hop
in that you allow into your room and um
and the conversation goes wherever it is
wherever it goes so I had a little bit
of like a dinner party in a way and so
there's like for example one of the
rooms I liked was the guy nivi telling
the origin story of angelist which I had
never heard before but he was like all
right I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna
tell you the origin evangelist and it's
actually like not what I thought he's
like we had Venture Venture hacks the
blog and that was kind of popular
and then I was like
I was trying to figure out what to do
like how do we turn this into a business
and so I emailed Naval Naval had owned
10 of it and I was like all right well
uh hey I don't know what you think about
this but like I'm thinking about selling
this PDF like okay Venture hacks is a
free blog but then here's this PDF like
we're joking about like the webinar
thing it's like dude even some of these
awesome people did it he's like I'm
gonna sell this PDF that will uh like
just give people like templates and
Naval is like okay that's cool
um you know for my 10 just keep it with
how this like this awesome PDF thing
you're gonna try to do like go ahead and
hold on to my ten percent I don't need
it you need it more than I do and then
he's like he's like then we're driving
home from some events uh after I had
told him about the PDF thing I was like
ready to go do that and Naval had this
like I you know like we were shooting
the and we had this idea like oh
you know what I really want is like I
want a list of investors and just what
they invest in what check size because
people are always asking us due to
venture hacks like hey do you know any
investors that would invest in my
startup he's like I just want a list
that I can refer to as like here's all
the investors I know here's what they
invest in and here's the check size so
when someone asks for an intro I can go
look at the list and make the intro
and then he's like yeah that's cool I
don't think that's a business like it's
gonna that's gonna make less money than
my PDF but like you're right that would
be really useful for us so he's like so
I went home that night he's like I made
a form and I emailed it out to every
investor I know that was like yo what do
you invest in
um what's your average check size and
what's your email address and like you
know are you open to people contacting
you about like for introductions for
deals he's like and I sent it to people
and they immediately filled it in it was
the ugliest form I didn't even pay for
the premium he's like just a reminder
that like you know you just need to
start you need to get it out there and
like get momentum going and he's like
now
um I I with any project if I can't like
launch some version of it in the first
24 hours it like kind of like it bothers
me a lot like I don't really want to do
projects but I can't do that he's like
so that was the first that was V1 of
angels we got this these people back and
then we put it on a we put it on our
website
and then we like got some like press
coverage because it was like oh here's a
list of all the angels
and it was like on all their emails were
there so that was bad so we had to take
that off and then hide their emails
because people were just getting
spamming them he's like and then that
became like the precursor to what Angel
list was which is now this like
multi-billion dollar company was like
just this list of Angel Investors and
that was the simplest like useful thing
and he's like uh and so he's telling the
story in the air chat and he's like if
you guys want by the way like I could
tell you the two other ideas that we
like you know two other paths that we
looked at that like turned out to not be
not be a good idea is but um you know
let me know and then you could see that
this now I'm like oh okay I'm gonna
follow along I kind of want to hear this
oral history of angelist and so it's
cool in that way right like it's a it's
a cool new app so
he's coming out with this and he's like
I'm a co-founder of this and the other
guy I think who's behind it is that guy
Brian norgaard I don't know how he says
last time exactly yeah yeah yeah um
who's kind of like well respected in the
tech scene uh as like a product guy a
product designer guy and they like work
at a Tinder or something yeah he
basically like he started a couple
things that like
had a bunch of hype but didn't fully pan
out but we're cool products like didn't
work but we're cool and then ended up
like had a product at like the match
group or something like that at IAC and
so then he like ran Tinder
um
and now he's like doing this I guess so
that's kind of like one one app so give
me your you haven't played with it so
it's hard to get your quick reaction
well I yeah you gotta like stand up for
a weightless
do do you think that uh do you think
that this is gonna be like a thing
I do not so I I think it's gonna be
it's actually reminds me a lot of
Clubhouse
um in that early on clubhouse was
awesome it was awesome because it was
such a curated community and it was like
they brute forced only dope people onto
the platform because that's who their
friend group was and so early on with
Clubhouse you would go into any room and
it'd be like super interesting
conversation you could just hop in and
meet people and you could build and I
told my friend this there's a guy who
used to work for me Jason
and I was like Jason he was still at
twitch after he got Acquired and was
kind of like you know spinning his
wheels a little bit and I go Jason you
should just forget about twitch I said
every night you should go on clubhouse
and hang out there for like five hours
you will build like the best network in
Silicon Valley in the next two months if
you just do that because I was like
you're an awesome talker people love you
when they meet you but it's just hard to
go meet like the Power Players Clubhouse
is this place where all the power
players are hanging out and they want to
be talking to randos because that's what
Clubhouse is and that they're excited
about Clubhouse therefore they're
excited about talking to randos I was
like you can go in there and go from
Rando to a friend in like two months and
he did exactly that he went in there he
started hanging out and he built this
awesome friend group They still hang out
in real life today he ended up raising a
fund out of that group of people like
dude you seem like you know a lot about
crypto like can you invest some of my
money in crypto and he's like uh I don't
know and ended up raising a few million
dollar fund invested it made these guys
money triple I think he doubled or
tripled their money and paid it all back
and gave away stop the fund within like
a year which is like incredible and um
yeah he just like had this awesome
Network experience so to me air chat's
like that right now you go in there
everybody's smart and awesome and like
the who's who of the tech world and so
it's great for me as a user right now I
don't think it'll stick like that and I
also don't think it'll catch on to be a
mainstream social media thing because
for one reason audio is too slow
people can like scroll and read I don't
know some crazy like three or five times
faster than audio and so there is uh
it's too slow any social media you're
now competing with Tick Tock it's like
how do you compete with the
entertainment per second that you get
rate that you get from an Instagram or
Tick Tock or even a Twitter it's all
short form bite size just instant
dopamine hits and it's like podcasts
it's very hard to compete with that
it'll never be as like you know billions
of people are just opening this thing up
all the time because the audio is too
slow and you get too few like hits of
Awesomeness per uh per minute that you
compare to your other options and other
buttons on your phone so that's why I
don't think it'll become like a
mainstream thing
tell me about this tradie thing okay so
Dom who was the founder of fast.com
which was a funny what's the third
what's the 30-second story of fast
Thursday story fast the guy gets this
domain fast.com comes out with crazy
hype on Twitter of just fast is gonna be
the like the next big thing it's one
click instant checkout what Amazon did
with one click checkout we're gonna do
for the rest of the internet and they're
just pumping on Twitter how fast it's
gonna be awesome they raise a bunch of
money at a huge valuation they're
bragging about hundreds of millions
right hundreds of millions hundreds
pre-launch uh yeah pre-traction
basically and
a few of us were kind of like
I don't know man I'm not sure like
where's your customers why what's going
on and uh
sure enough the bubble pops uh people
sort of
realize that fast.com has basically no
traction it had like I don't know like
tens of thousands in Revenue
as it had like you know almost a billion
dollar valuation and uh the product
doesn't really work that great the team
is whatever it all just falls apart I
don't remember the exact details of how
it fell apart like but it fell apart
they were burning I think 10 million
dollars a month of investor money at one
point something like that between three
and ten million I don't remember the
exact numbers but they were burning an
absurd amount of money he couldn't raise
anymore because they had no track no
traction at a certain point the
investors want to see traction and so
fast just combust and then it comes out
that oh this guy Dom
previously had built a company in
Australia called tow.com that was
supposed to be Uber for towing your car
and tow truck drivers
and basically like that company also had
a dope domain toe.com.edu and uh raise
money it got a bunch of press
got sub users but not a lot ran up a
bill that he couldn't pay like a 13
million dollar bill or something like
that he's getting sued for by the the
government there because I like Towing
contracts that he couldn't fulfill and
uh ended up just like leaving Australia
and like starting like you know he used
to be Dominic Holland and he rebranded
as Dom in the US and and uh and did
fast.com so it's kind of like okay this
guy's track record so now he's got
tradie.com
another quick domain name have you seen
this thing tradie like uh yeah and yeah
and so explain what it is and I'll tell
you what I heard about it so it kind of
looked on the surface like most of Dom's
ideas it sounds kind of like a good idea
I said it says the fastest way to grow
your trade business and he just shows a
bunch of like you know Blue Collar types
oh this guy does like Landscaping this
guy's got like a tractor
um and it's like hey we give you a
website we let you do your customers
book you and pay for you online we give
you easy way to do invoicing you know if
you're a professional you know trades
person uh you should be using trading
that's the that's the pitch
it's not a bad pitch I think it's a good
idea now tell tell what you heard about
because I think we heard the same thing
okay so here I'll read it so someone
tweeted they go looking at treaty.com
um so far 80 of the businesses I've
contacted from the site meaning there's
a bunch of businesses that were listed
as testimonials and I think he said it
looks like Dom's at it again right
that's the frame yeah he goes down he
goes you got it again he goes 80 of the
companies that contacted from the site
don't seem to be real they're shell
companies with fake Yelp and Google
listings and ninety percent of them
didn't poke up didn't pick up the phone
uh trady said one treaty made their
landing page without permit oh one
person who was listed on the website
said that tradie made the landing page
without that company's permission and
two so far seem to actually be using the
product but tradie is giving it to them
for free and sponsoring them and then he
shows like all the domain names that the
same LLC that owns tradie has also
bought all these other domain names that
were listed on the website of tradie.com
yeah this has got Justin Mitchell J
Mitch is the guy who uh
who tweeted this out and so uh so yeah
like straight off the bat and now by the
way I think all those are gone from the
tradie website so
with that and again my takeaway is run
I'm not not touching this thing instant
reaction
all right and the next two Tip Top uh
and Bay Area times yeah let's skip that
one let's do the pomp one so uh pop
friend of the Pod is doing something
interesting I don't know the full story
I haven't talked to him about this have
you talked about this Bay Area times
thing no not yet do you know what I
didn't even know about it I don't even
know what it is okay so uh go to
bayareatimes.com it looks like so pomp
is famous for he was one of the early
guys who was a very vocal about crypto
he started a podcast YouTube channel and
now he's a whole personality he's
pivoted away a little bit from crypto so
now he's just talking about business but
also a little bit politics and sports
and all types yeah his kind of relaunch
I want to talk to you about which is
basically like how do you think that's
going and gonna go so he was the Bitcoin
bull he he popped off in terms of uh
he's built his audience around Bitcoin
and saying how amazing crypto is and
then people will know like you know the
kind of like the the crypto kind of
haters basically will be like dude look
at this he removed the red laser eyes he
removed all mention of Bitcoin from his
uh bio
um and now like he hosted a real estate
conference the other day he's uh hosting
like you know startup events
um you know just like normal start of
things he's doing this like his Media
stuff is not about crypto anymore and so
you know I think he's diversifying and
kind of Shifting away from I think it's
working really well too yeah and like I
I would just say this I think for most
people it's a very hard transition I
would not want to bet against pump I
think he is a very formidable smart
person who is going to be successful and
whatever he chooses to be successful at
and I think he's chosen
I'd like to build my old code to be
about these these things instead of just
this one and um I think it's a very hard
pivot to make and he's making it very
well he's doing it very well so far from
what I can tell so basically he owns
right now he owns I think he owns
executive recruiting company a research
company
a course that trains you to get jobs in
crypto
and then one and then maybe like two
more
um and then I think he's investing
beyond that so here's what he said he
goes introducing the Bay Area times this
is a new product that uses data and
visuals to analyze what's happening
across business finance and Tech on a
daily basis so you go to Bay
areatimes.com and he basically says
narrative dominate the headlines on
other platforms writers spend paragraphs
regurgitating the same points over and
over again these Legacy products take
too long to read they bury the data deep
into paragraphs and it's hard to recall
the information but what if you just
want cold hard facts what if you want to
see the data in a single chart what if
you don't have 10 minutes to read every
morning that's what we built this for so
every morning they send out a email
that's got five big stories it's got a
visual
um which is like a chart or a graph
along with a few bullet points no hidden
agenda no Twist of facts no bias
narrative that's his claim so he says
he's been testing this with 20 000
readers and the feedback has been
phenomenal
um go for it right so you could see it
looks like it's built on sub stack
so let me go to the first one all right
so
like the one that he sent out three days
ago it's basically here's the data it's
like
what's going on in the stock market
what's going on with Bitcoin gold
ethereum et cetera and then
it'll be like uh here's a chart on life
expectancy and it says life expecting
has been stagnant for the past 20 years
after the cover drop it's at 77 years
old which is the same level as 2003
right so that's like the one big chart
and then the bullet points underneath it
so he's basically using visuals to and
data to explain what's going on in the
news I think it's cool I think the worst
case scenario here for him is that this
makes like two or three million dollars
a year and it's very very profitable the
best case it becomes hustle morning Brew
whatever it gets millions of subscribers
that make tens of millions or however
much more
um I think it's cool
what do you think I kind of wish this
was an actual printed thing
I like people that are going into like
newspapers and magazines right now I
think those are very interesting so
there's um Agora the newsletter company
I always talk about they would say that
they would charge like two grand a year
and they would send you like a
newsletter but it was a financial
newsletter except when they say
newsletter they would literally mail it
to you and they still do that and it was
just printed on like printer paper
and it was kind of cool for that reason
right and I actually agree with you I
think that could be cool where you just
like literally mail someone and it comes
in like one of those tan envelopes and
it looks like it's almost like uh here's
like the here's like um
like I think the president every day
gets like a briefing it's like a
presidential briefing where it's like
here's what you need to know and like
oftentimes I'm like just a piece of
paper like just give me that but at my
house totally and I actually do think
that would be cool did we talk about
this jumbo mail marketing thing
what's up so I saw this on Twitter it's
pretty cool so basically
um they they go the tagline is this have
you ever received a package in the mail
and thrown it away without opening it
neither have we and basically they're
like
90 of people 90 plus percent of people
who receive like a stuffed envelope like
a stuffed package will rip the thing off
and open it so if you go to
um the Twitter is at mailjumbo it's
basically the icons this elephant and it
goes we create jumbo chunky mail that's
guaranteed to reach your audience it's
good for Real Estate Investors home
services and business buyers
um and basically that what they do is
like you they just do Direct Mail like
kind of like you know here oh we got a
bunch of uh you know like spam in the
mail like oh whatever we want to buy
your business or we're a real estate
agent whatever but they do it in these
jumbo packages just to increase your
response rate so they're like yeah it
costs more but you're actually going to
get more people to to read your thing
and I thought this is like a brilliant
simple like side hustle style business
that I think also will get to you know
mid seven figures in revenue and be a
profitable bootstrap business of uh just
jumbo mail marketing there's this guy
named Sam Evans who've talked about that
like 10 years ago he had this course
called consulting.com and he would teach
you how to become a consultant whether
it's like how to do SEO for companies I
don't know what services the consultant
would do but he would teach you how to
start a consultancy business and here's
one big thing that he I don't know if he
says he invented it but he goes this is
like my stick is I do this thing called
lumpy mail where I said just a normal
envelope but I put something lumpy in it
like I forget what he would put but like
a figurine or a pen I forget whatever it
was but it would make it feel like the
envelope had a little bit of weight to
it because the reason I do that is
because when lumpy mail gets opened way
more and I can get your attention way
more and so what these guys are doing he
used to call it lumpy they're calling it
jumbo so I bet they like learn about it
from him but and he claims that it was
amazing well the guy who's behind it one
of the guys is behind it is the same guy
that does uh is the mobile mobile home
park guy on Twitter
um who also does like nine other
businesses and is like completely he's
like if somebody downloaded the podcast
into their brain and then their brain
said let's do all of them he just takes
he's doing like nine ideas at once at
all times he's kind of a Madman but this
is one of his ideas and he did it
because when he was trying to buy
businesses like I think like the mobile
home like buy these mobile parks mobile
home parks he needed to do Mass Outreach
and he wanted to increase his response
rate of are they actually even seeing my
my offer uh or that I want to buy their
their their business and um how do I get
them to reply and so I think this was
part of the the inspiration for that
I think we should wrap up here but as
before we do it I want to give you Kudos
you said something last pod that was
very sunny that totally flew under the
under the radar and if you made it this
far 60 Minutes in I'm gonna give you a
piece of gold that you can go to see Joe
that you're going to tell your friends
we said something about like breaking up
with someone maybe it was like breaking
up in the business really relationship I
don't remember but I said something like
it's not you it's me and you said yeah
it's not you it's me in that I think
you're horrible
and I've regurgitated that joke this
weekend
killed it the ring the the room they
loved it I looked so funny there was
such a you said that light and it
totally like went into the radar look
it's not you it's me and that I think
you're the worst
so that is like a free joke I've just
given you something all right um I've
given you the listener something what do
they give us when we give them something
right nobody just takes right you don't
want to be a taker that would be yes
that would go against our agreement that
we have with our listeners I've just
given you something Sean gave you
something that I now uh gifted to you
now I want you to go to our YouTube page
and
are I always thought the iTunes page and
that just shows how old I am I don't
know what the pop the podcast and like
the Apple podcast app go to both of them
and click subscribe because if you've
listened to this we've given to you by
the way drop comments on the YouTube
that is now my favorite part of the
podcast uh because for we did this for
two years with no YouTube and there's no
feedback loop you don't get any comments
on the podcast app but on YouTube people
leave comments and now we get I don't
know I don't know how many it is like
maybe 30 40 comments per per video
um I love I read every single one of
them every single time like no joke as
it's like my only way to kind of like
interact dude they're all say they're
all saying you look ripped now
I do like that part of the comments not
gonna lie that is a good good feeling
they're like wow
but it's also one of those like what do
you call it the I had a before before
and now I'm a before photo you had you
had a way before picture yes exactly I
used to be the way before and now I'm
just the before and I think people
recognize I appreciate them for that
um you can see you definitely have some
some you got uh some Set uh definition
bicep triceps you got the steps
I got sepsis over here
but I'm going to start commenting back
uh to about anybody that says something
interesting and uh and to that spammer
out there that keeps trying to trick all
of our people into a WhatsApp group
I'm hunting you I'm coming for you
because the YouTube algorithm can't get
you I will get you I will find I'm sorry
it's hard I have a unique set of skills
that have prepared me for this moment to
find you on every single video and
remove your comments yeah 10 years of
Googling has prepared you to reverse
image search and figure out where
they've made their mistake
um all right we're at it that's the pot
we'll see you all soon
[Music]
thank you